I want my baby my baby big baby baby big
Chili's baby baby oops
Bobby you foul I had nothing to do with
anything just unnecessary I'm hungry
Oh what is going on YouTube now there's
a lot of things I don't understand this
world but particularly there have been a
few things they've been bothering my
mind now I don't know if I'm getting old
or something but rappers don't make any
sense to me everybody won't be a rapper
but none of your [ __ ] makes sense and I
cannot be the only one that feels this
way
why don't I always do this so I got a
few questions be on you already know
what it is
LGI baby let's get it let's go now I
mentioned this in a blog befo why the
[ __ ] is every rap to talk about doing a
woman like it's a violent crime let me
tell you something if I was a woman in a
Jew came up to me and said I'm a Manny
Pacquiao your [ __ ] up that's like a
girl coming up to a dude and be like man
I'm a fight that they call rich no you a
we definitely this [ __ ] even R&B songs
are sexually violent as hell nowadays
about beat your titties like a pair of
speed bags whatever happened to love
songs with sexual lyrics like say huh
want to some freaky to you baby they're
gone and I'm left with thugs telling us
to treat a coochie like his own death
row let me ask you something what crime
has your vagina done for another man to
tell you they gonna murder you're going
to gates your the problem is every time
a rapper says some [ __ ] to a bunch of
hood rats that's right a little bit
safer and they laugh at that [ __ ] like
it's funny I put that kuchela chokehold
up whatever Big Daddy
and by the way that [ __ ] don't work
unless you got money and no class should
I try the girl I was going suplexing
booty hoes she's I don't understand what
broke rappers talk about [ __ ] they don't
have I got money I got hos [ __ ]
typically something you ain't got money
with me you ain't got hope [ __ ]
that's some simple ghetto mathematics
the square root of you being broken ugly
as [ __ ] equals you touching yourself
more than you should talk about data
from the bottom now a year unless here
is unemployed and living with your
parents
you should be wrapping data from the
bottom now he's not without now he's
still at the bottom believe why can't
y'all just brag about [ __ ] that you know
about and experience for example look at
jay-z when he was young he was about he
struggled as an artist selling drugs and
trying to do [ __ ] and make it out there
see now this new so damn rich every time
he reps it makes me feel like a piece of
[ __ ] it's your boy y'all broke his foot
how the hell do rappers go broke I don't
understand how you make like 44 million
dollars in a fiscal year and blow that
in like six months you get rid of your
debts by Pankau some nice cars and take
it your family that's it take something
ghetto [ __ ] they should've never gave
you money but share so you been broke
your whole life how can you throw all
that money away every two cents away
from sucking some ghetto Soulja Boy buy
a diamond studded pop the truck
why [ __ ] your pinkie ring coulda fit
all Africa you selfish [ __ ] now
recently I heard a rumor about you being
broke mmm now Percy do I believe that
you're broke ah not really
but just in case you are I wrote a
couple songs for you soldier boy broken
[ __ ] now we got a custom did you broke
as [ __ ]
that's right sociable I've called you
out you ain't rich something you think
that Tonka truck is balling baby that
ain't ballin jet if you were really rich
you wouldn't buy something ridiculous
how much you want to bet Bill Gates got
the cure to cancer and asking you the
corn with an accent butter [ __ ] are your
pants getting tighter and tighter listen
you can't be a thug and have that [ __ ]
tight that don't make any sense Mac in
my name you are real sir you had a
weather [ __ ] extra back tire up on the
cops of note are you gonna hide a gut in
there how you go where's your dick that
[ __ ] ain't dug baby he's asking somebody
to butyrate for you hmm I feel old
saying all this stuff but somebody got
explaining [ __ ] to me [ __ ] I used to be
a rapper got dust out my old MC Mike is
that what you call an MC Mike is that
right
they called me a key command flow sauce
egg foo young Szechuan sizzle over 15
copies sold worldwide [ __ ] I bought
them on myself
please move right here just get the late
what's not good what that make sausage
not more let's uh that's a food
reference for you guys watch Food
Network's from Seoul sausage it's
nothing new with penis or penises penis
I pewter sizes